there would be a blow up
and
at first it was just to throw something
smash some things
um
loves to smash up a place an apartment
furniture is what it started with glass
threw a glass at me and i started to
notice the pattern of escalation where
he'd
throw glass or turn over a table
then he would hit the wall and then he'd
hit the wall really close to my head
you know like when i'm standing there
you know just hit the wall screaming at
me
um
but
then he would um disappear
and get clean and sober and he'd come
back and tell me
that he had he was done drinking he was
over it he's done cleaned himself up
he'd done it before and he'd do it again
and then he would go back to this like
wonderful like
almost like
just unreal
like real you know but un
unbelievably
nice sensitive kind warm generous
interesting funny man that i loved
and he would
make me feel so
loved like it would get
i would feel so distant from that thing
that was so scary that i would
not even recognize it too and that was
how you know our relationship kind of
started to develop in that first year
do you remember the first time that he
physically hit you yes please tell the
jury about it
it was so s
it's seemingly so stupid so and like
insignificant
i will never forget it
i changed
it changed my life
i was sitting on the couch
and we were talking we were having a
like a normal conversation you know just
there was no fighting no argument
nothing
and um
he was drinking and
um i didn't realize at the time but i
think he was using cocaine because it
was like there was a jar a jar
of cocaine out on the table
i realized that sounds weird but it was
like
an actual vintage jar of it
but i didn't see him use at the time so
i didn't really factor that in i just
you know he's drinking and we're talking
and it's there's music playing and he's
smoking cigarettes and we're sitting
next to each other on the couch
and i asked him about the tattoo he has
on his arm
and to me it just looked like
um black marks it like i didn't know i
didn't know what it said it just looked
like muddled faded tattoo that was hard
to read
and i said what is it what does it say
and he
said it says wino
it says why no and i um
i didn't see that i thought he was
joking
uh because it didn't look like it said
that at all and i laughed
it was that simple
um i just laughed because i thought he
was joking
and
slap me across the face
and i laughed
i laugh
because i
i didn't know what else
to do i thought
this must be a joke
he said you think it's so funny you
think it's funny
you think you're a funny
and he slapped me again
like
i was clear
it wasn't a joke anymore but i don't
know what else to say or do so i just
stared at him i didn't say anything i
didn't react
i didn't move or
freak out or defend myself right or
say what are you doing you're crazy i
just stared at him because i didn't know
what else to do
and he slaps me one more time
hard
i lose my balance
all of a sudden
realizing that the worst thing has just
happened to me
that could possibly happen to you i
realized that i
i wish so much he had said he was joking
because it didn't hurt didn't physically
hurt me i was just sitting there on this
on on this carpet looking at the dirty
carpet wondering how i wound up on this
carpet and why i was
never why i never noticed that the
carpet was so filthy before i just
sat there thinking how much time do i
have to i figure out what i
need to do
because god did he just hit me
no i didn't want to leave him i didn't
want this to be the reality i didn't
want to
have the man i was in love with
i know you don't come back from that you
know not dumb i
i know you can't hit
a woman i you can't hit a man you can't
hit anyone and i wish i could sit here
and say i stood up and i walked out of
that house and i drew a line and i stood
up for myself
before i know it he
starts crying
and you know like i i have never seen it
an adult man cry and he's crying
tears i mean just falling out of his
eyes he gets down on his knees and he
grabs my hands and he's touching my
hands and he's
saying to me i will never do that again
i'm so sorry baby i i put the [ __ ]
away i thought i killed it and it's
it's done i i ki
i thought i put the monster away
and i've done it before it's done
i didn't say anything i made a point
to not say oh it's okay or anything like
that i just didn't say anything
i got up i went to the car i sat in my
car
and i felt like i sat there forever i
didn't want to turn the key i just
leaned my head up against the window
trying
to will myself to
have the strength to
know what i should do in this moment
because
i was
heartbroken